[Music]
see you all again after lockdown period
and although we've seen each other on
zoom I thought it wasn't a very
satisfactory way of meeting in some ways
it's quite different you can't really
know what a members thinking you can't
see they the same let's do I think the
staff did particularly well in keeping
in touch with us as individually and as
a council and I must just say at the
start me is not here but if he had been
I would have said to the mayor and our
councilor members well done on the
annual plan I think you've done it not
that we're fully aware of what's in it
yet but you have got what would appear
to be a great outcome for the district
at one point five percent increases
doesn't hit businesses as hard as before
4.2 whatever it was was so I'm sure that
wasn't easy but well done to the
counselors and staff on there now just
for your information this evening well
we have now beckoned sort of normal
times and this meeting is being
live-streamed tonight now the good news
is there's no picture it's not visual so
you can I shouldn't have told you that
should it's not visual but it is local
so please don't turn your mics on at all
until you get the call for me to speak
so just indicate to me when I'm looking
around that you want to speak and I'll
make note of it but don't put your light
on as a signal because that will distort
the broadcast side of things so all
right we move on now
apologies I have one apology from Andy
wills Robbie 8:45 for Robbie these
apologies we accepted move by myself
segment by Duncan all those in favor
please say aye the country carried there
any conflicts of interest appear to be
none
the first item is on pages now you're a
board appointee on that that doesn't
give you necessarily a conflict most
members that are on a board like that if
they're asking for money just simply
don't vote I think that would be the
first way so that's a just ask their be
noted you can to clear a conflict if you
want to but if council pointees don't
actually have direct conflicts all right
right
current register of interest pages nine
to eleven it's all there it's just to
put that in place you wish to speak to
okay at all or is it this was decided
the end of last year and you've had
email requests for information most of
you have given me that and I have put it
in place if anyone at a later stage or
somebody who's forgotten just let me
know and I will have it amended and we
submitted on to the web any questions
it's quite straightforward someone
prepared to move we receive it moved by
Sarah
seconded by Duncan speak to it put that
all those in favor
sorry
yes I said that before mm-hmm okay
now we come to comp item for
confirmation a minutes of some time ago
two pages 12 to 19
someone prepared to move except those
moved by Jason seeing that Monique I'll
put that all those in favor please say
aye
country carried any matters arising
don't appear to be now we come to the
deputations and presentations and we
have Rob McLeod near and clerk of the
regular Alliance Club if you like to
come forward and you've got up to 10
minutes who make your presentation yeah
I'll turn my light off and you turn
yours on and at the end of it there may
be questions of you so welcome sit down
and feel comfortable okay
mr. chairman and board members my name
is Rob McLeod representing the ring
representing the regular Lions Club
beside by at me I have Erin Clark as
support person yes I fall over he is at
the chairman the president of the
reindeer BMX club and also a vice
president within the angular lions club
itself we are in the process of trying
to obtain some form of storage we've
been putting up with problems with
finding spaces for our storage and all
our garages and sheds around the back
place and when we come to have an event
of some sort we have an issue of knowing
where exactly it is who's got it and
what they've got so our intention is to
purchase a shipping container it's a 20
foot shipping container and we would
like to place this next to the BMX
club's shipping container on their site
at the BMX club that's it would be end
on end with thiers
it's a
makes for a very safe and easy storage
and access for us through the BMX club
area we've explored all different other
options which really don't really come
up to power on what we are needing this
will give us a single location
easy access we've been in discussions
with a BMX Club of course and their
committee has indicated that they'll be
happy for it bring your alliance club to
place this container next to the air
container we're the shield from children
from the view from the road by the pine
trees and they've approved they've
provided the approval and writing and I
assume you will have a copy of that
letter from the next Club the land of
course is which the BMX club stands is
on II can land environmental kendry and
least to the womack district council
council staff has advised that we need
to apply for a license to occupy and
that the angular ashley community board
has the final say in granting this
appreciate that we believe the site is
appropriate it was not detract from any
amenities in the area the main
attraction is the BMX club of course
there is already a container in place as
I said it is well she wrote from the
public view and has easy access does not
affect any neighbors the regular Lions
Club as a non-profit service club with a
good reputation in our society we serve
and work in local environment here and
we will guarantee that we'll keep this
area as pristine and keep the container
clean and tidy as it if we do get the
approval to place it there we ask the
support of the regular Ashley community
board to endorse the generous offer that
has already been afforded us from the
BMX club and I'd like to thank you for
your time and for this presentation and
your consideration in the future thank
you just quick question to Kiev will let
application to occupy come to the next
board meeting or later than that do you
know
as a spec to grant macleod of the green
space team earlier yesterday and he has
taken on board matter and he says he'll
double-check sometimes all it needs is
in addition to the original blossoms to
occupy because the beer makes club is
already got the license to occupy we
might need to only just put the lion's
name in as a sort of sublease but he's
looking into that now with the property
section and he's going to come back to
me as soon as possible so it is in hand
at the moment
it made a few little kinks but I assume
is north
and seemed to be any em robbed the
situation is the board here's a
deputation we can't make a decision
tonight
that is gifs just see it will come but
we can give you an indication I think
can I just say the board is there any
board member at this stage that has any
concerns about it so so that might just
give you some idea that the board is
likely to be fairly supportive I think
so
thank thank you very much for coming and
good luck with it
I must say that other organizations
might want to follow suit that could be
the only difficulty but I can't see it
at the moment yeah well done thank you
now we move on to you lend on cusp rural
recycling facility welcome I'll turn
this off you've heard what goes on you
turn yours on and you've got up to 10
minutes Lawrence
most people just know me as firstly I
just want to say thank you mr. chair and
thank you board members for giving me
some of your time this evening I'm here
is the secretary for the caste community
network I'm also one of the moderators
on the castling Facebook page I'm on the
PTA as well and I'd like to think I'm
pretty good representative of the caste
community but here tonight talking about
the caste community networks requests so
I'm here to talk to you in ask for your
help to get the caste community rural
recycling facility back to the caste
community the council agreed to a
12-month trial
following recommendations from community
boards and now they are sort of
indicating that they may not reinstate
the bends that have been taken away
after spending quite a bit of money in
time on sealing up the facility
including a purpose-built then for paper
and cardboard by waste management we
want to know why the bins aren't being
reinstated in why was the trial
interrupted anyway I understand the
conditions of that cupboard 19 have
caused however because it is a
non-contact facility we'd like to see it
reinstated as soon as possible so the
cast community network is asking the
ring here Ashley community board to
support the reinstatement of the trial
and if possible to extend it until the
end of the year in order to give a solid
six months worth that new been to see
how that goes
we hope that you were able to support us
with this and thank you for your time
questions I'll be quite honest with you
from the board's perspective we're
unable to say we support you or we don't
support you at this stage because the
board would have to get a staff report
so we hear both sides of it before we
make a decision on on that so what we
can ask for as a staff member on there
at any rate which we will do so we get
their position my understanding is that
the hazardous they're the solid and
hazardous waste working party is meeting
either the end of this month or at the
beginning of next month to discuss net
but the assurance I can give you from
here is that the three of our four
councillor is here that's Robbie Kirsten
and Paul are all members of that working
party so they in the situation they will
have heard what you have to say tonight
so that really strengthens your position
to a degree so any any questions I'm not
sure
answers the question but I know nothing
about it it's news to me
RZ at the opening but did this happen
all of a sudden or wasn't an incident it
created the issue that the burners went
away to your knowledge so to my
knowledge the bins were taken away in
March which is three months short of the
12-month trial that the council had
played and budget of war agreed to and
arranged there had been the occasional
issue with some paper and cardboard
flying around the council had actually
addressed that in fact thereby providing
a purpose-built then there were no more
shoes there were some confusing messages
put out possibly I miss my knowledge
there were no issues we were just told
that jutsu covered 19 that the Ben would
be the Ben's were they removed as the
Southbrook facility was closed and
everything was shutting the council was
obviously looking to reduce costs in
difficulties however it's a non-contact
site the only contact is when the truck
driver has to come and hook up the bins
to take them away people don't take
anything they go there they check
everything and it various times yeah
does it answer your question stand that
the council hasn't made a definitive got
a definitive position as to whether it's
absolutely stopped or whether it will
continue that's something the committee
will be in discussing later so yeah from
my understanding Robby know a lot more
I'm not gonna make any speeches because
it's going me but I'm gonna ask the
question in your weird there was no way
to take it the Eco central closed
Theodore's
it was now we take recycling was being
leaned filled no I wasn't aware that
there was no way to actually take
everything so are you saying there was
no you to store everything there was
that ring you were us so they were just
not
it would big the question that now that
Southbrook is reopened we would have
expected the bends would be returned at
the same time as South preparing iPad I
think with the amount of discussion air
recycling just in the last couple of
months PI paper on that I mean I think
we should be supporting something like
this I thought this was what the people
wanted done
the fact it was actually being taken to
take Delhi perhaps would have been
better to have just done it and not told
the people because even I think the
problem has come there that some people
got pretty relaxed about the recycling
and not to worry about it worse if they
just lift it as recycling and don't rate
where it went do we get this whole thing
sorted it might have been better for the
community
Chryst is now right you're much better
off not hearing me pool with with will
thank you very much I know that's a bit
frustrating for you but it's yeah we'll
just have to wait to see really so thank
you very much right moving on
reports 8.1 pages twenty to sixty five
and I'll give you the page numbers as we
go through because if you follow the
agenda they get a little bit wrong from
now on so yeah so that this is one on
the speed limits bill were you dealing
with this I will just tell you if you
have a look at and I'm sure most of the
board might have being equally confused
if you have a look at the agenda
recommendation and you have a look at
your recommendations in the full report
they're they're somewhat different the
numbers are all different on the roads
the recommendations are different in one
instance so just so you know if you get
some questions when it comes to making a
decision
I will go off the I've had a look at off
the agenda recommendations if that's all
right by you and incorporate the one
another recommendation you've gotten the
main report so it's a wee bit confusing
that yeah okay over to you bill great
thank you so this report follows on from
consultation that was done on speed
limit review in the area that that's
we're calling the to a Huey to Ashley
but as effectively line side road
through to the Ashley River area we
consulted back in September on a number
of speed limit changes in that area and
the results that consultation are
included in the report it would be fair
to say that that generally the the
consultation
responses were supportive of the changes
that we were proposing although not
overwhelmingly so and and particularly
with Pegasus Boulevard
it was fairly a fairly close close thing
we also drink through that process
consulted with the NZTA
who raised I guess three significant
concerns that with our proposal and they
they were around tolls road and NCTA was
suggesting that our recommendation or
our proposal to reduce the speed limit
on tolls Road from a hundred to eighty
wasn't going far enough and they
indicated that they thought there were
significant safety issues on tolls Road
and they were recommending a speed limit
of 60 the mega maps a bit of software
that identifies safe and appropriate
speed indicated that the safe and
appropriate speed on tolls Road was
sixty we had some discussion with them
and in order to get good compliance with
a with a 60 K speed limit on on that
section of road we thought we would need
to do some significant work to it NCTA
suggested that we would need to do some
significant work to bring it up to a
standard where it is safe enough for an
80 K speed limit and eventually we
agreed with them that we would reduce it
to 80 at the stage and we would
investigate options to upgrade it to a
point where it's suitable for an 80 K
speed limit and bring them forward for
consideration and in the LTP so that is
that's where we've ended up on on tolls
Road we had also suggested through to a
Huey following some discussion with the
Runanga that with what a 40 K speed
limit was was
appropriate through to a Huey and
particularly past the school and the
Madurai and through to the Audubon
the agency were not supportive of of
that and they suggested that the limit
remain at fifty
they also also we went back to them
again and discussed the variable 40 K
speed limit outside the school which
they supported but we also note that the
government is proposing or has a
proposal that they're putting forward as
part of the the safe network program to
encourage road control authorities to
reduce speed limits around schools to
forty K s all around urban schools to
forty K's on that basis we we have
agreed with the agency that we will
leave the the speed limit will bring to
to council the leaving speed not at
fifty through to a Huey and discuss with
the school and the Runanga some
alternatives for reducing it outside the
school in particular and that could well
include a variable speed limit but
hopefully we'll have a little more
information on when the government
proposes to allow us to reduce it to
forty it's a permanent speed limit and
and the agency has indicated that
because the the rule at the moment says
that that they can't reduce it as a
forty K speed limit there they wouldn't
be supportive of that as it stands the
third area of concern with the agency
was Pegasus Boulevard and we have they
were suggesting that 50k was the safe
and appropriate speed on Pegasus
Boulevard and again we don't believe
that that would get very good compliance
and in the current environment through
there and so we have discussed it
further with them and we have agreed to
reduce it to 40 sorry to 60 from 70 and
we bought this to the audience if stand
board on Monday and their response was
that they would like to leave it at 70
at least until the NCTA has decided what
they're doing with the speed limits on
the state highway so just just for your
information that that was a response
from the system board and the fourth
area that we had some discussion with
the agency over was unsealed roads and
we had suggested reducing unsealed roads
from a hundred to 80 the agency is
saying that they would support going to
60 and that the current operating speeds
on all of the unsealed roads that we
have an inlet area is around the 60 to
65 K sort of sort of range so the
insisting that on that basis 60 is
appropriate they're also saying that as
we progress with the the changes of the
government's proposing we will become
under a regional speed management
environment and they believe that that
will result in a or potentially could
result in a regional blanket 60 K speed
limit for and sealed roads so that those
are the
that the agency had and and our
responses to them happy to take some
questions first question why would you
want tolls road at 60 kilometers and
therefore there's a rule that was
certainly the attitude that the staff
were taking in our discussions with the
NCT a - he we at 40 kilometers an hour
is it a standard speed a good way the
confused awful it was just 50 K 70 and a
hundred this 40k a speed around the
hearing yep under the new speed
management rules the standard speeds
will be 40 50 60 80 100 and 110 so 60 so
40 is a speed that is being encouraged
for urban areas and particularly low
value local roads in in urban areas and
so we will be coming under some pressure
in the next little while to reducing
speeds now urban areas to 240 KS other
than arterial and clicker roads bill can
I
question just um clarification because
look I read this whole thing and I
couldn't help but gree with the unlit of
them on the Transport Association page
Samaritan but but though if we went to
page 33 for example a new outline and
how you consulted or are you with me and
we went down to 34 and to Young's Road
for example here with me um you've
consulted with the people at ATK's is it
her Iridum you're recommending 60 and
support for that is 65 percent
so if 10 people have done that row does
it mean there's six and a half people
but the angel in CB is oh you know I'm
not just trying to make it hit here here
they're all kind of a
had responses across a number of areas
and particularly we had hardcopy
responses and and SurveyMonkey responses
so we're at this stage I probably go
back and look at how many of those
people were living on on each particular
road but it may well not specifically
include the people who were living on
that road so it was across all of the
responses that we got so you alluded to
the simply nine responses so we've had
four 79 responses to all the charts and
the roads had been in front of us is
that here over it and it would be
possible for summary at Browns Road Oh
CooCoo to comment on house road down
near the bridge is that Heather's house
system works thinking
when you have a quick
look at the agenda here and your report
you'll see you'll see that differences I
referred to in the agenda our local
roads here numbers one two three four
and five they're all in the board area
and then down the bottom 22 23 and 24
are also in the board area but when you
look at this numbers they're quite
different on your report as you'll see
not that that means too much but I just
thought the board might want to clarify
or may consider moving that we agree
with certain numbers in our board area
and note those that are not and the
board area and have no opposition or
whatever I don't know what someone might
like to move but we should certainly
have a view on the roads and re reaffirm
view definitely and my I think so and
then you have a in the main agenda you
don't you have a tolls Road but in your
recommendations for us on this on the at
the end of it tolls roads in the report
but it's not in the original agenda
recommendations you want that in the you
want that in the motion I presume in the
notes yeah is that clear for everybody
it okay with someone prepared to move
well we're just looking at each other I
I'll taste the meeting and you know I'll
go off the the easiest one I suppose
I'll move as set out in the not on the
agenda as set out in the report because
it encompasses everything that a we
receive the report be we the board
approves the one two three four five
twenty six
27:28 and then the board notes the other
roads are not within the board area and
has no objection to the recommendations
does that cover it quite happy to
discuss it I'm just trying to think as
I'm sitting here all I'm saying there as
we support the ones in our board area
and we're not objecting to any others
and this someone wants to yes I could
write it's complicated one is Coldstream
Road from the end of the existing 50 to
the multi-sports - is Coldstream Road
from the east end of the multi-sports to
Smart's road which is our border 3 is
golf-links road for is marchment Road 5
is Smart's road 22 is Marsh Road 23 is
campsite because that's just the border
running around the river there 24 is
yang's road they the roads in the board
area because that help you Kirsten right
there's someone happy to second that or
got a better idea
that's not an aboard area for it
the powers rows just out of the board
arias one up from where we come in we
come in on fern side and move down to
Young's Road yep we can second that if
you like all right well I don't need to
speak to it it's quite clear what I've
moved supporting the board ones and have
no op there's no objection to the ones
outside it of our board all right Robbie
sorry
to say I'm going to be abstaining and I
didn't declare a conflict because this
is just recommending to cancel winning
gets to cancel or will be declared a
conflict and not participating but I
didn't want to be in case we have any
questions I could have assisted with but
I will be under staining and just
quickly it's never easy to get these
right there'll be people who object and
there'll be people who think it's windy
so the the main issue I always see with
these speed limit changes as the road
has to meet the speed limit so the
condition of the road should be in the
right state that people will actually
understand that that is the speed
they're supposed to be traveling and my
only slight concern which I'll be
raising it counsel is will it cost to
upgrade these roads to these lower speed
limits because we simply don't have any
additional money in the budget analyst
NZTA is going to come forward with this
be limit review and provide additional
budget for us to actually improve the
condition of these roads to actually
make them look less like rural roads
doesn't say due to it consideration for
ic2 of healy people around possibly
speed indicator devices I said sign the
junk I'm guessing it might want
potentially I certainly thought that do
they have anything currently or are they
gonna possibly get it you council has
four or five speed indicated devices
which we cycle around a number of sites
around the district and we're in the
process of setting up or identifying a
site into a hue to to cycle to move them
into okay question okay and the only
thing it concerns me about the motion at
this stage is we have Marsh campsite in
Young's Road for example and previously
when we've done this exercise
have you had any major feedback
regarding consulting on one speed and
actually doing another so you could
argue that the counsel was inconsistent
or well told us some verbs but have you
ever had the feedback hey you consulted
on something and done something else and
why was it we haven't had that that sort
of feedback and certainly in these
processes I think this is the first one
where we're recommending something
different to what we consulted on so
we'll potentially wait and see
Thank You mr. chair yes this report here
is to give clarity as to the intentions
with regard to the budget we currently
have for South Brook Road
the board has as aware of this
particular issue and has previously been
briefed about the intentions well about
the issues in and potential options with
regard to South Road I think at their
briefing I think it would have been
obvious to the board that there are a
lot of conflicting issues on the stretch
of road and probably an awful lot of
views as to how they are best resolved
in therefore without spending too much
more time on it there the purpose of
this particular report is to give some
focus to the funding we have currently
at the moment and to delay the bigger
wider conversation about improvements to
South Brook Road until such time as some
of these other works and investigations
have had time to be carried out and beat
it in I think it would have been clear
from the council other board briefing
that the NZTA funding that is allowed
for this type of works is very clearly
aimed at a couple of issues ie safety
and modal shift
whereas probably the board would see
other issues as being more worthy of
attention in that stretch of road and so
I think if we continue down the track of
investigating the wider bigger option at
the moment it's likely that we will find
ourselves continually at odds with the
funders and probably struggle to get any
reasonably agreed outcome in terms of
what
what we should be doing long to him with
that stretch of road and given that
there are two or three other or more
than two or three there are four or five
other initiatives either already
underway or being closed off at the
moment it will be I think in in in the
staffs opinion it is worthwhile and
delaying any major decisions on there
until the impact of those changes has
taken place
we had a short briefing with you mr.
chair in the mir and the transportation
portfolio holder councillor williams
during that briefing the the issue of
the consultation or the timing of the
consultation which has covered often
section 4.9 was raised and there was a
concern with that briefing that that
consultation was occurring too early in
the piece and that the they would prefer
to see her back to the board with
something a little more solid that would
then be agreed would be suitable for
consultation and so because of that I
don't think it's any we don't have any
changes to the recommendations that are
in front of you because that timing
isn't mentioned in the recommendations
but I would live to the fact that the
staffs intentions of this paper is
passed is that we will be completing an
options report before the end of July
and reporting back to the regular
advisory board on the 12th of August
with our recommendations for expenditure
on that stretch of road then there would
be consultation occurring at which time
there would be a further regular meet a
report to the regular advisory bring
irrationally community board in October
and then we would be aiming to complete
a tender process before Christmas and
hopefully have works
completed before the end of March the
works that we would be focusing on
relate largely to trying to improve the
safety for pedestrians in the area we
think that would be something that would
be both agreed by the board as being
something very useful and agreed by NZTA
in terms of their purpose for the
funding and so that the next steps would
be that we would be looking at what
options there were for improving that
and bringing that back to the board
we're very aware that the 425,000
probably won't go a long way towards a
full scale improvement of the
pedestrians as such as a signalized
intersection crossing but they other
sorts of things will bring back once we
have got a little further down with our
investigations here other than that I'm
happy to take any questions one question
from me and do you think it would be
helpful Paul is the council's portfolio
holder and it might be helpful for the
board have him included in that group if
he is willing to just seem sensible to
me so he was moving it could consider
that as an option to add Paul's name to
if Christians so just a completely
clarifying where does that 425,000 come
from and how much of it is contingent on
NZTA funding the 425 was really I think
you'd have to call it an allowance
rather than a an estimated budget to
achieve a particular purpose so there
was started in life as $450,000 for the
purpose and I had understood the purpose
although I don't think it's listed in
the council resolution to allow the
funding but the main purpose was to
investigate options
and look at what we could and should be
doing now that's an awful lot of money
to spend only on investigations so I
would assume that there would be some
intention to also begin works on
whatever was determined but it is more
of an allowance I think rather than a
budget element that you could say that's
what we had funded at for so it is in
the budget for this coming year in the
council budget well it's being carried
over to this coming year and so it will
be available to us if this was as missus
past entry question just my
understanding of that original budget
passed by council was that it was to
improve congestion in the Southborough
area particularly as well as improve the
pedestrian experience why why wouldn't
we spend money on that and why are we
getting in ZTA
to actually be the person who takes off
what we do in that area if it's our
money the 425 is the total budget of
which 51 percent as NZTA funded
we know him
this this project is so good luck I just
like to think dawn air in the mirror and
Paul for including me in those
discussions the other day it sort of
there was a bit of a shock I hadn't
realized that the government of funding
the changes of criteria is as marked as
it is that it's all about modal shift to
pedestrian and cycling and congestion
and motors and roading is all gone and
you're starting to see that too when you
have a look at you can't go up a ski
field if you want to put chains on or
it's snowing anymore I mean things we're
going man some of these areas but the
point I thought I picked up from the
discussion with you this is not
necessarily lost to dealing with
congestion because the answer to fixing
some safety particularly the children
crossing the school and coming out of
the air could well mean and digitize
them or lights the dangers road for
example which may also go a long way to
dealing with congestion on a short-term
well you have a look at whether you want
a four-lane at or whatever so it's not
all totally lost but the language we're
talking it is Sarah I think anyone else
the reason I asked the question
that is wearily use it or lose it
situation if we don't spend it then half
that money goes back to NZTA we don't
want to lose that money I can see the
scenes and what we're doing but but it
is very disappointing that this is the
main highway into and out of wrong you
are
it's the it's an absolute condition
problem and actually improving
pedestrian access in this area may
actually make it worse for congestion
the only thing I can hope is it will
encourage people to use the Western
route that we've invested quite heavily
in and but I can see a lot of people
being very unhappy about the lack of
action in this area in terms of
condition because it has been the most
complained about area that I've known of
enduring your in my time and council yes
I I have the great iron fingers when the
very most compared completes issues we
have and I think one minute we're
talking about traditions and cycling our
times we've discussed their hair
dangerous the whole strippers for
petitions of cyclists and why would we
encourage or go along those ways I
scribble them I think just probably what
one night said there's a danger of
pleasing nobody Ellis you're going to go
around try and please everybody I think
there's a danger that you'll please
nobody and I think what Kristen is said
about alternative routes I just went in
where are we with her at wooden road
stay higher one roundabout if they're
not going to do the the bypass routine
for another 10 or 15 years there's still
some mere being out to disperse the
traffic so we set up this not so
attractive
I think the solution I've looked at this
quite quite some solidly with Jared and
looked at plans and looked at
alternative ways for the children to get
out of south of school through maybe
purchasing some some land and to noonim
Street and bypassing to having to go
down through South but Road to get out
from school but that doesn't seem to be
doesn't seem to be a solution so for me
I think we really need to be looking on
the long-term plan the solution would be
to get a road that extends from nine
side road east of the railway my
instructional book Road and I know that
isn't in the long-term plan and I think
we need to bring that forward and I
think that would leave the situation
greatly and in my mind that is really to
be solution in the long term the several
school and the pupils that go there do
they actually come from basically a
surrounding area is with some ways he
walk from that side and have to cross
the road to get to the school or our
parents if you bring them from further
afield I could pass an opinion at the
moment but I think that will be exactly
the purpose of the consultation is to
really sit down with a school with some
options in front of them after the board
has considered that and talked about how
many of these students were I think
probably you know we could all say you
know there's probably three ways people
get to school
they are either walking and crossing
from the Coronation Street side or
walking down from the town end of things
that the south build or they're driving
there and I would have thought for my
own perception that the majority people
were actually driving there that the the
local catchment so to speak of
residences that are close enough to that
school I would have thought would be a
relatively small proportion of the total
school role but that's exactly the sort
of thing we would be checking through
with the school as we
firmed up on our ideas just just very
briefly to Bodmin reward and nearly to
thousands I was a strong advocate for
that for that route unfortunately some
adverse headlines in the newspapers
because somebody was going to cost 20
million dollars to do and also some some
unhealthful traffic data stop that
killed it finished it although we've got
designations on some pieces I don't know
if we can still link or not
good evening Gruen
so you I'm here today to seek a decision
for the Community Board to consider
changing the name of Road types to be
approved as part of the Townsend fields
such a vision and renderer this is
basically come about because of roads
that have originally approved in the
lair plan of surgeon has changed which
means the designations that were given
at the time and are longer applicable so
I trust you've all headed through the
report and I will answer any questions
you may hear for me got one Scott and us
it's the naming of the word using that
of the word Crescent Crescent is
generally accepted as a curve moon
shaped curve that comes off and back to
the same Road this one doesn't are we
setting precedences if we start doing
this I mean in reality it's a street
isn't it oh there we go
said the time I had advised the surveyor
or the developer through this surveyor
that that would probably a street would
be more suitable in that crude christen
does not fit with our policy of because
I see something has to meet meeting the
same theraphy I think that's what yeah
plus you see it and also I have checked
other streets in our district in most
most if not all other and that same
layout so I do tell them that street so
if clear doesn't media policy so it I
don't think they would it be unhappy if
it was changed just tree yeah
so you also over at CMD as well then you
have to prove those yep I saw you okay
I'm eight point four pages one five
three one five nine welcome good evening
thank you for having me I think most of
you know me but if not on Grant Stevens
part of the green space team and I've
got a report for you this not about
roads so I'm hoping you've had a chance
to read read through the report but I'm
just to summarize with him being
approached by the local Baha'i community
of Y mercury who would like to add an
additional six trees to the area in
deadly pact
we're to were previously planted along
with a park bench the location of those
is shown in the at the end of reports
for you but in essence goes along the
same line of the existing trees that are
there and the seat would be roughly in
the middle of this looking back towards
the nipple courts the cost of this would
be meat entirely by the bahai assembly
but in order to plant trees or install a
seat it does require your community
border approval and there is an ongoing
maintenance cost mainly associated with
the trees obviously and seven years as
they get established we need to do a bit
of work to keep them alive so I've put
in the other debt is estimated around
forty dollars per tree per annum and can
be met with for our existing green space
budgets yeah have you taking any
questions
sorry that's I was just curious the
location of the seat because I mean it's
you're sitting with your back to the oh
sorry
oh excuse the location of the seat I
thought was funny that you were sitting
with you you know most people sit with
the Sun on their face we're told the Sun
with zip seats positioned facing you
know East I didn't think it was going to
be a very popular spot because of the
location of it in sort of slip being in
the middle of the pack you know halfway
along the pack just seemed to me odd and
odd location yeah so the the location
and direction of the scene that did come
as a request as part of it from the
bahai assembly and I guess in terms of
the Sun you you would get a nice warm
warm face in the early mornings be
easier you're right as sort of from
lunchtime onwards it's it is gonna be
more in the shade I guess if we were to
turn it the other way it would be
because there's already trees along that
then each of the boundary you you
wouldn't be in any more Sun facing the
other direction and so the the thinking
was saying he was kind of looking out
over the pack if the board would like to
request a different location for the
seat I can certainly take it back to
them and then yeah this is where that
they had I guess proposed it and we
didn't see any major issues from a green
space department on this the reason I
say
is because a lot you see foot like you
can see with your walk and they tend to
walk on the south side of the path and
cut across across the grass they're
hitting two white streets so hitting
West and so their foot traffic wouldn't
maybe suggest people would be more
likely to sit on their the end of the
pack if you don't see so many people
cross that you know go across the side
of the pack this way we're asleep was
any positioned but yeah yes that's what
I say I live nearby is he yeah and I'm
not against us at all but what is the
situation with vandalism on young trees
do the council get many of the new
plantings vandalized and if they do who
would be at the cost of replacing them
and how much would that be
just thought on it side of it yes we do
on occasion here vandalism to young
trees as far as I understand standard
two that have been planted they haven't
had any issues as of yet I've been in
place for approximately a year I think
in terms of replacement costs should
they be damaged I would anticipate that
would probably come to Council as just
as part of our when trees die or
something happens to them we have a
replacement budget that covers their
reinstatement in terms of how many get
vandalized or the river that's likely or
not there's probably not something I
could comment on
are we gonna take into consideration the
location are we gonna be going back to
them and asking them okay yes I was
gonna
the recommendation no I wasn't no yeah I
think it's very good
like this to donate year and why I
didn't move that recommendation or an
altar of the seat well if they're paying
for the seat and let's see wishes to
hear but I think may not be the ultimate
place to have it but you know it's at
the the recommendation and their cost so
that's why I think it's fair so I'll
move that recommendation
yes this is an application or two
applications to your discretionary fund
the regular Croquet Club actually sent
this application in and just missed the
March agenda so they've actually been
waiting for some time for this
that's money so I think they'll be quite
relieved to know one way or the other
whether or not they're getting a grant
from you I think it seems like quite a
good one but it's up to you obviously
the board the second item is North
Lebanon funds and School Association
which is like the period the Parents
Association it's not specifically the
school requesting that there is some
question about whether or not the school
can keep the swimming pool running due
to maintenance costs of chemicals in
such like the Hans School Association
believes that this is a facility and an
asset to the area and the whole
community use it it's not only used by
the school and they would hate to see it
being closed the community uses it a lot
to help teach children to swim and they
are asking for the board's assistance to
keep it open by supplying the required
chemicals during the season
oh sorry I'm step to find it I will
approve please my hundred dollars each
and it's said that if they granted the
subject to education board funding just
that the community might see their in
the past I'm trying to understand what
is the difference between the e request
that was turned down because it was a
school and this question just passed
just noting not trying to change the
resolution I'm just noting that's a
difference of what you've done in past
could I just make a comment and all the
years I was involved with school
swimming pools schools never got enough
money to maintain them never ever and I
always had to go to groups like us to
get a bit to fill the gap and especially
for cubicles
mr. Chia this is this was also hit a
slight difference from some of the other
facilities which were for school use
only and this was for a wider community
benefit
if we did this just before lockdown and
it's been and been and been gone through
to the council the council's deliberated
on it and so it's just the ratification
to dot the i's and cross the t's
is it normal for a counselor to actually
move a submission to the council I
didn't believe that we normally would
how will the council as staff and
yourself in councillors interacted with
us and how well you had done in a
difficult decision making around the
financials and the annual budget for
this year so I just let you know that
the board's most appreciative of the
work councils done okay now moving on
8.7 another ratification this time it's
to Environment Canterbury yes this is
the same along the same lines as the
previous one the mayor I think presented
to ikan the council submission and I
think Jim presented our and I think
we've had quite a good outcome from our
submissions in that ikan seems to have
listened and I think they are reducing
the proposed nine point six that they
had initially indicated that this is
just brick retrospectively ratifying
your part in doing that job
this is as big pan
ha
since so long ago to be free the only
comment I would pass an opening is I'm
Stanley key and a number of calls
regarding future playing propose who was
around for heat years and whether they
will continue or will that we contained
or ceased so out in the farming
community I think it's coming out slight
concern there that some people do feel
that the preps an option may be taken
away from them and people don't give up
your options very easily so it is coming
a topic of discussion and the only other
point I'd like to bring to your
attention was and said these priests the
tree third of May there's a need for
some fancy high-rise things obviously it
the old red line Sykes yep
they call it founders corner does
anybody know or could tell me the
history of there and what I'm getting to
is tonight we've had discussions around
street names with our district and we
hit some authority over them one could
argue that this is a developer
developing a site and using a name that
they believe will sell the site but
given the next 20 years ringing with
such great change or some of the growth
in the area there may be some other
iconic names that may slip away from us
and if we don't sort of be slightly
proactive or all investigators whether
we as the board have an opportunity to
name them is against the development
will come back him though
since icing that Duncan should raise
their I pulled the same thing out and
the original building there on the
corner was the parrot building which was
one of the first that was a wooden
buildings stores in regular I hadn't
heard where that was any connecting
connection with founders corner for
years that corner was Red Lion corner or
being Zed corner whichever camp urine
I've never heard of founders corner
maybe we should okay try and find some
backgrounds that David is probably
to be quite honest but what if any
controller we have I don't want to see
developers coming and put their pet
names on the major corner that is the
major entrance into the town as you come
in to give it a false name if it is a
false name so perhaps they can following
up can we get K to follow it up and see
what we can find out about that and if
anything I don't have any view one way
in that with the names right but I think
we should have a discussion of element I
don't really have too much to say to be
honest um I've been working pretty much
full time throughout over 19 so doesn't
been room for much more as soon as we
were able to go over a crowd of teen we
got the Y mech walking group out pretty
quickly and we went out to the hurinui
destructon did a Steven K walk out the
year I mean that felt normal and it's
nice to have the spec I think nice to
feel about a normality but otherwise
that has been quiet community more wise
for me and getting me a new plan really
ready to go but I'm just a bit of an
update I had a meeting yesterday with
wegg which was the first time with with
the with the accessory in disability
people and the district and what came
out of that meeting was that some of the
concerns with was they thought that
everybody cooked pretty well but some of
the concerns were saw the elderly were
that were banking and getting care shot
in phones with some people so I thought
that was quite interesting so that's
what came out for me dick what came out
of that meeting I know that that
everyone was well looked at from the
district and a few people that might
have been left left
Cortese and heating assistance was due
to probably banking and in phones and
not being able parently 40% mm-hmm some
areas of people over 70 do not use
computers and some areas 300 over
300,000 in New Zealand don't know how to
use computers in excess banking and
things like that so I think that I think
that might be something that we might
need to talk to the bank's about a lot
of people still for the next 10 or 15
years need to be able to go into a bank
and to get their money out as opposed to
not having that serviced by the bank so
that's something that I I picked up from
during the lockdown I think we've been
zooming and zooming out and have been
zooming so much I think you might for
bill rice to come and put a year speed
restriction on his own minute but he
hasn't at the stage that's quite good um
yeah I've just been pretty much full on
with but eroding but some pieces water
management side but them but surge and
transfer stations that's a there's a bit
of everything really so that's probably
too much to give a decent report but you
know and I think most councillors have
been actually very very busy during this
and locked the ensign Aereo on zooming
and I think the public had probably more
time to be sitting down ringing
councillors and asking and discussing
things as well because I've had all this
time on their hands to be certainly and
bringing their local representative so
being quite a busy time of on bit of
everything really
we had a month ago I had an experience
Rose given a rung up and I was to come
and pull three tractors out of a ditch
along eastern port road in consequence I
got myself involved in a between
neighbors over a drain
one neighbor wouldn't clean it and it
was affecting the other neighbor so I
rang the councilman spoke to appropriate
person who sort of said there's not a
lot they can do so I advise the owner
well advise the people that had the
issue to get it cleaned and tell the
owner that they're going to do that and
and build them for it I don't know
what's heaven since but it just brought
me into just how neighbors can squabble
and when I spoke to the council person
on the drains the troublemaker was known
to the council people from the neighbor
from the other side so um there was an
interesting issue I think it's resolved
thank you just to bake up Kimball
Williams's comment about how busy it's
been in just think we touched on at the
start of the meeting was regard to
rubbish they say water sewer and rubbish
were vital issues and at the start of
the lockdown trying to keep in
particular rubbish as operational as
possible was incredibly challenging and
the mayor and I went up yesterday
to the SF book and gave a letter on
behalf of Council to waste management
and Irene for so as the comments I think
I've mentioned to this board during in
particular this they haven't just been
our contractors they've been our
partners and some very trying times so I
was very pleased to have the opportunity
to go and he'll be honest it's a leader
but it certainly meant a favor to waste
management to have that acknowledgement
and some of the stories are here with
regard to the abuse that their staff and
by extension some of ears as most of you
are aware they are aquatic staff they
the pools were closed and so they
volunteered their services to civil
defense they were assisting phone orders
at the supermarkets when the transfer
stations were able to take cares they
were accused
that needed to be assisted in and out of
the facility so there was a heck of a
lot that was happening and behind the
scenes to keep that essential service as
operational as as possible you can
imagine the situation we've all seen it
overseas where all of a sudden solid
waste is not being picked up in the
health hazards that in turn creates so
it was an incredibly busy period just
with regard to that meeting the sodden
hazardous waste working party against
out of the meeting I've seen Kenny
through a list of potential dates on on
Monday she'll go through and look at
Diaries or other members before
something comes out but we're certainly
trying for our fingers 30th of June or
the week and a half after the end of
July forever for the meeting thank you
Alex the same wag meeting are the XS y
McCurry XS group as Joan and the the
concern with people who haven't got
internet access trying to get
information and perhaps the importance
of still continuing with hard copies or
it's like newspapers in there to get
information out to people was something
that was raised another thing I think a
problem with people in a rural area
we've got a beehive they've been put on
their boundary by the neighbor and
neighboring property and they've got no
way and another neighbor happens if
anaphylaxis in relation to bees but
there's no way to control where people
put bee hives on properties I understand
and I wondered if something could be
done is there anything about that sort
of thing there's no livestock locks and
yeah anyway it's all thank you could
bring Nick Harrison air and ask him if
there are any ways in dealing with some
of that if there is you could pass it on
us it's not just but Nick would be the
right person to ring there yes will
we've been fairly busy as you know with
the in your plan but the lack of
community meetings has actually made me
feel like I'm quite quiet I'm home
during the evening so I volunteered to
help with student volunteer army and out
the street and so I've been doing
groceries mainly and they're actually
now moving also into tech help where
they can actually offer students to come
and help people and they're partnering
with Charles up them and retirement and
village and places like that to actually
have the young people come in and help
them help the older people to use them
to talk to your relatives so it's a
that's actually built some really lovely
partnerships on the council side I
attended SSW twice with social services
while McCreary on zoom' the food banks
have gone absolutely crazy people who've
never accessed food banks before they
are under huge pressure and mental
health keeps popping up is a significant
issue and rent is going to help now that
the wage subsidy is finished so there is
going to be a lot of hardship hitting in
all districts so it's obviously
something that they're keeping up very
close eye on and on the good news side
the cuss community path has done down to
the community centre so next Anzac Day
we'll be able to all walk up the part
and the community centre I just asked
the question at Council and they're
hoping to have the initial work done at
the end of June so we'll keep posted on
that one this week we've got our the
district plan obviously has been delayed
their notification dates have been
slurred out and it won't happen till
2021 now we're still pushing forward
with all the know all the information on
that and trying to come up with some
sort of ways forward by talking to
various stakeholders going forward but
that won't happen in 2020 now and this
week we've got the land and water
committee tomorrow which we will be
setting up the era are a hot ERT our
working group just that the paths around
the rivers and actually looking at those
linkages so that's another small step
forward for us in their space
it's being reasonably busy at work
lately but on that note so I'd just like
to commend everyone that did actually
volunteer their time to come and help us
in supermarkets because it was a wee bit
a wee bit rough at times but in terms of
community board meetings and stuff like
that it's been a bit quiet for me you've
all seen I was a bit disconnected from
these meetings because the lake of and
we've camera I didn't put in submissions
three submissions on cycling and walking
strategy in the district not against
cycling but one of the issues I raised
was a bit worried about the conflict
between high speed road cyclists and
people are walking frames on the same
footpath and the other issue I did raise
particularly was the passing distance of
cyclists which is one and a half metres
and the vehicle and I think that's fair
enough to but they didn't seem to be any
requirement for where the cyclist was
placed actually on the road which had
the effect of putting you in a motor
vehicle on the wrong side of the road
and I thought there was a problem with
what I've noticed all the cyclists going
to work in the morning all riding very
carefully on the side of the road but in
the weekend they're all over the road
and that's where a problem comes and I
think I had further discussions with Jen
Peter Kostis of gray pair and met do see
in CDHP over improving the health
services up here and the health hub
we're trying to get more ophthalmology
done up here cancer clinics and I just
can't thing at the moment but we're
pushing to get these services up here
because we think that it will be more
convenient for the local residents
especially in the older ones and it will
also have a value to the hospital in
decreasing the number of cars trying to
pack at the hospital because I'll be up
here in sleep so that's the thing that
I'm working on and I've been talking to
the neighbors Stannary entity and and
I've actually written the lives the
council complimenting on that pathway
that foot between towns in Road
extension and Pentecost Road
it's made a huge difference because it
stopped people walking on the road and
it was a pretty narrow reign it was a
bit exciting in the fog then the thing
that I was asked today by some of them
down there they said there's a lot of
children walking through Green Street to
South Brook and then eventually going
down Ellis road we myself and
achievements discussed before having a
cycle way down to get through to the
other end of ten but there's no walkway
in Green Street if you remember
curricula at Green Streets being turned
into a giant drainage ditch so if
they've done a wonderful job on putting
a path on one side and I've written a
little you're clearly thinking for that
but I'm wondering whether they could put
one on one side of that drainage area
too so the kids can get from all those
hands up the other end of ten the end of
the south in because there's no way of
doing it without them going right around
the block and they're walking in the
grass and then the mud at the moment
which is very good anyway that's all
I've done at the stage anyway it's as
far as I can get from home I think think
thank you for that item 13 no
consultation projects item for teens for
your information item 15 I don't think
there any media items there are no
questions there's no urgent general
business
so we'll now move into the workshop
we've got Vanessa to talk about
innovating streets for the people pilot
fun
you
[Music]